[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
heroes path
a series in which we follow the journeys
the different heroes
champions and other key figures
underwent during the rise of ganon
otherwise known as the great calamity if
you haven't seen any of the previous
parts
this video might confuse you as it skips
any introduction and jumps right into
the story events taking place at the
moment the disaster starts
in that case i advise you to watch the
episode about link and zelda first
as that one gives a more thorough
introduction to the series and
its purpose joining me today is breath
of the wild scientist croton
who is best known for his amazing videos
about the stats
analysis and the inner workings of the
game if you are unfamiliar with his
channel
i highly recommend giving his content a
watch links to his
channel and one of his videos will be in
the description and the end card as per
tradition in this series
with that said let's get back to
business
the champions gather around zelda as she
returns from the spring of wisdom
having failed to awaken their ceiling
power yet again the champion shares some
comforting wards
and mifa tries to give the desperate
princess advice on finding the spark she
needs to unlock her sacred gift
however as fate would have it before she
is able to finish her last sentence
a huge tremor interrupts her and sends
her and the rest of the party in a state
of disarray
calamity ganon has finally decided to
show his face
and today of all days with some quick
coordination
the plan is clear link and zelda will
make their way to hyrule castle
while the pilots make haste for their
divine beasts to provide support to the
hero
and princess in their fight against the
demon king with the exception of rivali
the group moves along the stone-carved
roads of the linero promenade
at the west gate they take a left turn
into the canyon leading towards
cockregal village
the hometown of the chica tribe however
mifa never crosses to the village
herself
as link zelda and urbosa continue on
towards kakariko
mifa joins druk and moves over a quarter
shelf
after which the two scaled the cliffside
down into the lanero wetlands
gopanga village was a fairly large
settlement located in the wetlands
although creating a champion does not
depict mifa visiting the settlements
age of calamity might choose to alter
this scenario and we will see mifa
joined rook in fending off a possible
monster invasion in gopanga
this means that we might get to choose
between one of the two characters
in this mission providing the player the
option to play as the champion of choice
beyond this point mifa's journey will
mostly consist of traversing through the
water
so this would be a good solution to give
her some grounded combat sections during
the calamity
rather than before it although creating
a champion depicts their paths mostly
without detours
the champions wouldn't be careless about
innocent civilians in dire need of their
assistance
the book is a great piece of lore and
presents a good overview of the
estimated paths our heroes traversed
but at the end of the day it is just
that an estimation
diverting from these guidelines slightly
is not a crime if it complements the
gameplay and the story progression of
the characters
from the wetlands mifa moves east into
the rotella river and up around kinzian
island
she then crosses in between the pier and
boney pond
and east into the zora river which leads
to her home
zora's domain if age of calamity wants
to stick to the core story events
established in breath of the wild
mifa should never encounter a single
guardian on her journey
not only is it far too early for any
guardians to have arrived this far from
the castle
but zora's domain nor its surrounding
rivers or lakes were ever reached by the
automata
similar to kakariko village the domain
is obscured from view and hidden away
from sight by a natural border of
mountains and cliffs
making it one of the safer places during
the calamity the closest dead guardian
we can find to the home of the zora
lies east of bonnet pond close to what
will later be the location of the la
neru tower in the era of the wild
this location is still a long ways away
from zora's domain
and most likely just a leftover of the
army that torched kaponga village or
more garrison to the west of the
wetlands
no other guardian husks are found beyond
this point
obviously the zora thrive inside a body
of water whereas their average land
speed is no different than the average
hylian or gerudo
in the waters they can reach far greater
speeds
hence it's no surprise that mifa's path
consists of more than 50 percent of
traversal through rivers
however the zora aren't the only beings
who thrive in an aquatic environment
the zora river as well as the roads
running alongside it are notorious for
housing large quantities of lithophos
and although lizofoes seem kind of
brainless in breath of the wild
some of the backstory of the game
sketches a whole different picture of
these speedy water monsters
as according to the zora stone monument
one of the zora kings of old along with
this army was ambushed by a battalion of
these creatures under the command of a
lizofo's general
this indicates a clear intelligence and
coordination between these beings
and since they are now under the
influence of ganon and more restless and
dangerous than ever before
seen they may provide a decent challenge
since they are pretty much at the same
advantage while submerged
a water-based battle up the zora river
between mifa and hordes of lisophos
would be a perfect
fit for the zora champion we might even
get to choose to either engage them on
land or in the water by skipping between
the river and the roads next to it
similar to the case of ravali it all
depends on if the team at cui tecmo is
able to integrate this kind of gameplay
into the warriors engine
if not they might just stick to land
combat although that would be a shame as
it is not logical for azor ah to choose
land over water
especially when they're in a hurry since
mifa's journey tour divine beast is by
far the shortest of all the champions
and doesn't cross many important
settlements or locations
we will once again present an
alternative option to the one presented
in creating a champion
since according to the book once mifa
reaches the oren bridge
she moves straight into the zodobon
highlands and subsequently
up this unnamed peak which is allegedly
the standby position of varuta
however it is hard to imagine mifa going
straight to her divine beast without
checking up on zorro's domain first
despite the fact that her home was
spared the destruction by guardians
that isn't to say that it wasn't under
attack at all
as mentioned before the zelfels are
bountiful in this region
and historically the providence is even
notorious for being plagued by lionels
who reside in the surrounding mountains
mifa has plenty of reasons to chuck up
on her people but the one that stands
out the most
the safety of her brother saidan who was
just a young child
at this time and who mifa has a strong
sense of responsibility for
with this scenario in mind instead of
going straight to varuta
she continues up zoro river past ruto
lake and
into her hometown a battle at zoro's
domain between mifa the zora soldiers
and her father king dorafin and hordes
of incoming monsters would be a great
setting for some amazing action
sequences
where the zora must defend the great
zoro bridge to deny
access to any monster bold enough to try
to cross into their territory
not only that but this would also
present the option for us
the player to take control of another
character if we so choose
we are of course talking about king
doraphan himself
the king of the zora has been depicted
as a brave and battle-hardened warrior
himself in the backstory of breath of
the wild
when we stated before that no guardian
ever touched store's domain
this is actually not entirely true
though it didn't actually do any damage
to the home of the zora
one stray guardian did manage to get
dangerously close to the domain
in upland's arena the scar on dorothea's
head
is said to have been a remnant of his
heroic action to take down this guardian
some have speculated that this might be
the same guardian we found at bonee pons
however this does not exactly match the
story told on the zora monuments
as it is quite far away from zoro's
domain itself
whatever the case may be the fight
between dorafan
and the stray machine may actually be a
gameplay section
and solely playable as him as soon as
the situation at zora's domain is under
control
mifa finally makes her way to varuta and
readies herself and the divine beast for
an attack on the source of all the chaos
the demon king himself who still resides
at hyrule castle
but in a turn of events ganon releases
more strands of malice aimed straight at
the colossal machine
and seizing control of it with mifa now
trapped inside her corrupted weapon
a ghostly specter manifests itself
before her
eyes a being whose sole purpose is to
prevent anyone from retaking the machine
and kill the pilot within armed with her
light skill trident she desperately
tries to get the upper hand on water
blight ganon
but as we all know it isn't meant to be
mifa is slain by the demon king's
creation and just like her fellow pilots
her spirit will linger within varuta for
the next 100 years to come
unable to escape the walls of the
machine she was so proud to be chosen to
pilot
the death of the zora champion inflicted
a huge grief on her people
and zora's domain as a whole fell into a
deep misery in the days after zelda
sacrificed herself to seal away calamity
ganon and the flames of war
slowly extinguished the zora people
planned to send mifa's trident drifting
down zora river as a way to repose her
soul
however this act of remorse is
interrupted by mifa's voice who says
that the trident and her are one
and urges her fellow zora not to grieve
over her loss
but rather to remember it since that
moment her trident is kept safe
and cherished and a statue in her honor
is built
which to this day decorates the central
square of the domain
the zora have by far the longest
lifespan of hyrule's races
most of the zora elders present in the
era of the wild 100 years later were
alive during the rise of calamity ganon
and the zora princess still remains a
sensitive subject among her people
for her brother saidon who is now an
energetic adult and accomplished sora
warrior
the memory of the great calamity is but
a hazy dream
but due to the combined effort of him
and link during the era of the wild
mifa will be granted a chance for
revenge on ganon
not just for herself but also her people
[Music]
you